dear comrades, I congratulate you on the
successful pieces
of the Sarmat intercontinental ballistic missile, this is a great
significant event in the development of
advanced weapons systems of the
Russian army, the
new complex has the highest
tactical and technical characteristics and
is able to overcome all
modern anti-missile defense systems,
there are no analogues in the world and will not be for a long time to
come
this truly unique weapon
will strengthen the combat potential of our
armed forces will
reliably ensure the security of Russia from
external threats and make those
who, in a semi-rabid aggressive
rhetoric, try to threaten our country think